[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec cette semaine à mes
côtés au riad monsigny bonjour orienté
vote est notre invité est olivier
paccaud sénateurs les républicains de
l'oise bonjour à vous bonjour merci
m'accueillir merci à vous d'être la
semaine à tonalité très budgétaire au
sénat la chambre haute a démarré jeudi
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
2010 9
le débat a tourné autour de la fiscalité
écologique d'autant que lundi lors de
l'examen de la loi de finances
rectificative le sénat a dénoncé un
rabot de 600 millions d'euros au budget
de l'écologie ce que conteste le
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale s'est
penché sur la réforme de la justice un
texte d'abord examiné au sénat qu'il
avait largement remanié
mais l'assemblée est revenue à la
version initiale du texte celle du
gouvernement
faut-il interdire la fessée oui répond
l'assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi modem était examiné en commission
cette semaine le texte a suscité de vifs
débats d'utilité publique pour certains
ridicule pour d'autres et cette semaine
au menu du sénat donc budget et écologie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi les sénateurs ont démarré l'examen
du projet de loi de finances pour 2010 9
celui du pouvoir d'achat pour le
gouvernement mais le débat s'est
concentré évidemment sur l'écologie sur
fond de mobilisation des gilets jaunes
la chambre des territoires a voulu se
faire l'écho des inquiétudes des
français et d'un sentiment de ras-le-bol
fiscale résumé des débats avec samia
déchire en pleine mobilisation des gilet
jaune
les sénateurs demandent au gouvernement
de geler la hausse des taxes sur les
carburants
le budget 2010 9 prévoit une hausse de
l'athéisme pe au 1er janvier
elle augmentera ensuite chaque année
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
un effort injuste pour la commission des
finances pour un ménage se chauffant au
fioul domestique m nage qui utilise une
voiture diesel c'est pas forcément un
choix c'est le carburant des gens qui
travaillent et bien la pac décès au ch
de fiscalité énergétique ce ses 136
euros en 2018 et ses 538 euros en 2022
538 euros en 2022
à partir de ces constats la commission
des finances proposera comme elle l'a
fait dernière de geler les tarifs de la
tpe à leur niveau de 2018 pour ne pas
augmenter les taxes
la majorité sénatoriale demande au
gouvernement de maîtriser davantage ses
dépenses
l'an prochain le déficit public
atteindra 2,7 pour cent du pib pour la
première fois depuis dix ans le déficit
public en france est en train de
repartir à la hausse qui est assez
exceptionnel d'ailleurs malheureusement
en europe que monsieur françois hollande
vous connaissez bien vous l'avez soutenu
pendant ses deux premières années de
mandat a fait 37 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques et et belle macro au
même point en fait 51 milliards à chaque
l'exécutif renvoie la balle à ses
détracteurs pour le gouvernement
l'opposition ne peut pas lui demander à
la fois de dépenser moins et de
débourser plus pour aider les ménages à
faire face à leurs dépenses énergétiques
vous me trouverez toujours de votre côté
pour baisser intelligemment la dépense
publique et réduire la dette qui est un
poison pour notre économie mais dans ce
cas là aidez-moi voter les réductions de
dépenses publiques que nous vous
proposons
or voter c'est que nous avons proposé
sur les emplois et des autres et ne
proposait pas d'échec essence à 15
milliards d'euros
pour les français la fiscalité
énergétique a largement occupé les
discussions et devrait continuer de
dominer les débats sur le budget tant
que les gilet jaune resteront dans la
rue olivier pas qu'on vient d'entendre
un bruno le maire à l'instant ils vous
reprochent votre incohérences d'un côté
vous nous demandez de baisser la dette
les dépenses publiques de l'autre vous
ne votez pas les restrictions
budgétaires qu'on vous propose que lui
répondez-vous que l'incohérence les du
côté du gouvernement depuis
malheureusement un an et demi alors
allons sur le terrain du diesel on
augmente le prix des carburants sur tout
le quinquennat de façon forte mais en
même temps on va en même temps fermer
des maternités fermé des gares fermées
des perceptions en zone rurale est donc
obligé les gens à rouler plus on a
encouragé ces mêmes gens à acheter du
diesel donc l'incohérence elle est du
côté du gouvernement
après monsieur le maire je l'entendais
parler de réductions de dépenses
publiques mais les grandes réformes que
la france attendait et qu'avait promise
le président de la république les
réformes structurelles les réformes de
réduction du périmètre d'action de
l'état
on les attend toujours alors là la
majorité les républicains au sénat va
donc revenir sur la hausse des prix du
carburant vous faites le budget des
gilets jaunes ont fait le budget dont
les français ont besoin
vous savez les gilets jaunes c'est un
mouvement qui est très populaire qui
comprend des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de manifester et cette hausse
des carburants c'est en quelque sorte la
goutte de gasoil qui fait déborder le
réservoir des colères c'est un
ras-le-bol fiscales générales alors
effectivement le fait de ne pas
augmenter au 1er janvier c'est à dire
dans cinq semaines de 6 centimes le
diesel de 3 centimes le les sens oui
c'est un geste envers les gilets jaunes
mais c'est un geste dont la france a
besoin
et très sincèrement sujet des gilets
jaunes j'ai trouvé que l'attitude du
gouvernement était particulièrement
méprisante
si on recule sur la taxe carbone et la
trajectoire des hausses des prix des
carburants comment est-ce qu'on incite à
la conversion le nécessaire vers des
véhicules plus propres
alors d'abord il faut quand même sortir
de cette fable les français aiment les
fables de la fontaine il n'aime pas les
fables de de rugy et de darmanin la
transition écologique ne passe pas par
cette convergence diesel essence puisque
et tous les français le savent
maintenant 80 % 80% du produit des taxes
sur les produits énergétiques va non pas
à la transition écologique et
énergétique mais va au budget général
donc arrêtons cette fable les français
sont écologiques les gilets jaunes sont
écolos mais ils ne veulent pas qu'on les
escrocs qu à ce niveau là j'aurais été
tout de suite ce discours on va revenir
sur ce fléchage de laisser une petite
chose on va regarder un sujet dans les
dents quelques instants donc vous aurez
le temps de vous exprimer juste sur les
gilet jaune ce mouvement est ce que vous
parleriez de radicalisation comme l'a
fait le gouvernement ces derniers jours
alors il a parlé d' radicalisation il ya
trois jours avec christophe 4 cette
année et puis aujourd'hui il change un
petit peu de de braquet et il commence à
dire qu'il va vraiment prendre en compte
les volontés des gens et que mardi nous
aurons soi-disant des annonces c'est
très flou quo soit disant vous n'y
croyez pas écoutez on a déjà eu des
annonces il y a une semaine une bonne
semaine avec une un doublement de la
prime qui passait de 2000 à 4000 euros
pour changer de véhicule ça n'a pas
suffi à calmer la colère alors je ne
sais pas ce que va annoncer le président
de la république qu'est ce que vous
voudriez qu'ils annoncent déjà
effectivement un moratoire sur la hausse
de la tpe savez c'est pas raisonnable
sur cinq ans alors qu'on ne connaît pas
l'évolution du prix du baril
effectivement de prévoir des os c'est
quelque chose qui devrait se faire
chaque année dans le cadre du vote du
budget donc la première des choses
effectivement c'est un moratoire sur la
hausse des prix du gazole ou en tous les
cas
de la fiscalité énergétique c'est la
première des choses mais une petite
chose quand même sur les gilets jaunes
je dirais que qui qui sème le mépris
récolte la jacquerie et on a vu partout
en france puisqu'il ya eu près de 2000
points de blocage des gens qui sont
venus manifester vraiment plus que leur
ras-le-bol
une forme de désespérance une forme de
désespérance et notamment notamment en
ruralité j'aimerais parler quand même du
sentiment d'abandon de ces zones rurales
de déclassement un sentiment même
d'assignation à résidence vous savez
cette france des périphériques sommes en
parler christophe guilluy c'est cette
france où quand on ferme une classe on
ferme une poste on ferme une perception
on ferme une maternité on ferme une gare
on ferme une usine dans 9 cas sur 10
c'est chez eux
olivier pâques où vous vous nous parler
de ce mouvement d gilet jaune et il ya
un homme qui a essayé de les exprimer
cette colère cette semaine c'était à
l'assemblée ça était beaucoup commenté
je voudrais qu'on regarde cette image
ensemble cet homme c'est jean lassalle
député non inscrit qui a donc revêtu un
de ces fameux gilet jaune et le
président de l'assemblée richard ferrand
lui a demandé de l'ôter puisque c'est
interdit par le règlement refus de jean
lassalle
la séance a dû être suspendue le
président de l'assemblée at il eu raison
de sévir je voulais écouter le président
de l'assemblée est là pour faire
respecter aussi les les règles
maintenant jean lassalle
on connaît sa façon de s'exprimer des
fois un petit peu différemment il avait
chanté sur les bancs de l'assemblée
il a peut-être réussi un bon coup de
communication mais en même temps il faut
montrer à ces gilets jaunes qu'on est
solidaire de l'heure
de leurs mouvements qu'on comprend et
qu'on ne se contente pas de parler alors
c'est un geste personnellement je ne
l'ait pas fait je ne l'aurais pas fait
aucun sénateur n'a un filet de gilets
jaunes sur sa veste mais peut-être que
on l'a dans le coeur le gilet jaune
alors on va revenir à la question que
vous évoquiez il ya quelques minutes le
produit de la taxe sur les carburants va
t-elle à l'écologie bien non pour le
sénat le rapporteur général du budget a
constaté dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative 2018 un rabot de
près de 600 millions d'euros au budget
de l'écologie c'est une présentation
démagogique répond gérald darmanin
explications aurélien romano c'est
l'histoire de 577 millions d'euros du
budget rectificatif 2018 qui font
grincer des dents car en plein mouvement
des gilet jaune
une partie des recettes affectées à la
transition énergétique a été reversé au
budget général 2010 8 rectificatif la
droite dénonce une mesure injuste le
garnement très bien pu dire nous avons
une partie de cette fiscalité qui vient
de l'essence qui va du gas-oil pas
libéré français qui vient du fioul
domestique payés par les français
et bien ce surplus de recettes ces
quelques 600 millions d'euros de plus on
les affectent
on les utilise en partie plutôt pour
accompagner les français quand même plus
besoin
le ministère de l'écologie répond par le
simple mécanismes comptables habituelles
et déplore l'exploitation politique
qu'en fait la droite sénatoriale
il s'agit tout simplement de mécanismes
comptables qui ont lieu chaque année et
l'âge ça quand même déplorable que
l'opposition utilise ça pour l'exploiter
à des fins politiques pour faire peur à
nos concitoyens un ajustement comptable
qui aurait pu avoir lieu beaucoup plus
tôt étant donné que le surplus est connu
depuis le mois de juillet le ministre de
la transition écologique lui-même a dû
reconnaître une confusion dans la
communication
c'est de l'argent qui devait être
dépensé pour le soutien aux énergies
renouvelables est comme le coût des
énergies renouvelables baisse dans notre
pays eh bien on n'a pas besoin de
subventionner autant que ce qu'on avait
prévu
les énergies renouvelables donc c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais je suis
conscient que en termes de présentation
évidemment ça crée un trouble sacré à
une réaction d'incompréhension pourtant
son homologue au budget semble plus
nuancé et regrette le trop grand
fléchage de la fiscalité
d'abord en affectant
toute la fiscalité tout le temps parce
qu'on essaye à chaque fois de trouver un
sens on a un vrai problème
il est rare de trouver des fiscalités
qui sont propres à l'armée à l'éducation
nationale et je crois que nous devrions
tous collectivement ne pas sombrer dans
la démagogie c'est 577 millions
réaffecté à posteriori au budget général
sont donc un nouveau couac dans la
pédagogie du gouvernement sur sa
politique énergétique il sait pas que
vous avez entendu un bruit poirson dans
ce sujet les accuse d'exploitation
politique que lui dites-vous que le
gouvernement malheureusement n'a pas de
boussole écologique il a qu'une boussole
budgétaire en fait toute l'action du
gouvernement tourne autour de cette
problématique
allez trouver des sous et c'est vrai que
dans le cadre du plfr 1 et bien la
commission des finances du sénat a levé
ce lièvre qui est quand même d'un
cynisme absolu en pleine action des
gilets jaunes à savoir que 577 millions
d'euros qui en 2018 pas en 2010 9,1 en
2010 huit devaient être utilisés à la
transition énergétique ne l'ont pas été
et vont être réaffectés au budget
général monsieur mc ren monsieur
philippe sont comme le monsieur jourdain
ils font de l'écologie sans savoir en
fait ils font pas du tout d'écologie et
c'est ça le gros problème est que les
français ne supportent plus c'est à dire
que on leur ment on leur fait croire on
les culpabilise en disant vous êtes des
pollueurs
et pour changer d'attitude nous allons
vous obliger à aller vers des véhicules
propres et en même temps il voit très
bien que cet argent n'est pas utilisé à
l'écologie alors quand madame poirson
nous parle de cynisme de scandale
j'avoue que je suis sidéré vous savez
les français ils savent compter et il
compte bien mieux que les ordinateurs de
bercy
il compte au centime près quand ils font
leurs pleins de y comprennent les choses
et là il voit malheureusement qu'on leur
ment que le gouvernement leur ment et
c'est vrai que ce plfr c'est assez
incroyable en pleine polémique des
gilets jaunes vous demander au
gouvernement de reverser ces 577
millions budget de l'écologie je lui
demande d'être cohérent avec lui-même
si l'écologie est réellement une
priorité effectivement qui l'affectent
cet argent à ce à quoi ils devaient
affecter c'est-à-dire à l'écologie qui
respecte
la parole ce qu'il ne fait pas depuis
des années malheureusement alors olivier
paccaud pour conclure sur ce sujet de la
fiscalité écologique des gilet jaune
comment sortir de l'impasse pour le
gouvernement quel message lu à dreux
seriez vous aujourd'hui
vous savez je ne suis pas allé sur un
rond point spécifiquement le week-end
dernier pour pour rencontrer des gilets
jaunes mais dans le cadre de ma de ma
tournée du week-end j'ai rencontré des
gilets jaunes et il ya une dame avec
beaucoup d'humour qui m'a dit aux etats
unis ils ont donald nous on à picsou bon
évidemment c'est caricatural mais c'est
complètement vrai dans l'esprit des gens
et dans la réalité alors oui ce que l'on
demande déjà c'est là d'abord la
réaffectation de tout cet argent
consacrée normalement à la transition
écologique à l'écologie est un moratoire
sur les hausses de l'athéisme et pe
prévue pour 2019 et que ce soit
maintenant désormais fait année par
année
on va passer à notre deuxième thème la
réforme de la justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déjà voté au sénat la loi à portée par
la guerre de dessau nicole belloubet
était examinée cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale la
majorité et le gouvernement sont revenus
à leur copie initiale alors que les
sénateurs avaient largement modifié le
texte
l'objectif principal reste de
désengorger les tribunaux le résumé des
débats est signée nathalie guillois
principale préoccupation du gouvernement
le budget de la justice il augmentera de
1,6 milliard sur cinq ans soit une
progression de 24% encore insuffisant
pour certains députés de l'opposition il
faut madame la ministre
une ambition beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup beaucoup plus forte
nous proposons une augmentation en 2020
et de 50 % du budget de la justice pour
le gouvernement ces moyens
supplémentaires vont permettre la
création de nouvelles places de prison
nous livrerons eu sept mille places
supplémentaires par rapport à celle que
nous avons trouvé en 2022 et nous aurons
engagé ou terrains achetés ou
construction commencer nous aurons
engagé eu mille vingt nouvelles places
nous tiendrons ce que nous faisons autre
mesure qui fait débat la caisse
d'allocations familiales pour remplacer
les juges
c'est le sens d'une expérimentation que
veut lancer le gouvernement
la caf pourrait réévaluer les pensions
alimentaires pour les parents divorcés
sans passer par le juge
l'opposition y voit surtout des mesures
d'économies comme si la seule solution
pour que ce soit plus rapide et plus
efficace était de contourner le juge est
de ne plus aller devant le juge
bah non si pour être plus rapide et plus
efficace il faut plus de juge
alors mettons en oeuvre des recrutements
et plus de juge
l'assemblée a également voté la
simplification du divorce en supprimant
par exemple audience de consignation si
c'est un changement important de
procédure qui concernera plus de
cinquante mille couples chaque année et
qui je crois permettra de leur donner
satisfaction en diminuant le temps on
envisage de diminuer à peu près par deux
le temps consacré à cette procédure une
justice plus simple plus rapide ce sont
les objectifs de ce gouvernement avec ce
projet de loi qui sera votée mardi à
l'assemblée
alors olivier paccaud le gouvernement
donc rétablie sur l'essentiel des points
la version initiale qui
la sienne le sénat n'avait-il pas fait
de la surenchère par exemple sur sur le
moyen de la justice oui enfin une la
surenchère je ne sais pas mais le sénat
souhaitait donner plus effectivement de
moyens à la justice et le sénat
souhaitait que le président la
république tienne ses promesses à savoir
15000 places de prison par exemple alors
qu'il n'y en aura que sept mille donc
effectivement ça passe par plus de
moyens juste la ministre 10 qui on aura
quinze mille à la fin du quinquennat
non cette nuit effective et 8000 qui
seront créés qui seront lancés avant la
fin du graal a eu mille qui seront
lancés la nuance est importante donc en
fait c'est 7000 qui seront créés bon
toujours est il que oui nous avions
prévu mais ça a été retoquée par nos
collègues de l'assemblée effectivement
une majoration du budget tout à fait
alors le gouvernement veut se passer du
juge on l'a entendu dans un certain
nombre de domaines afin de désengorger
les tribunaux on a entendu l'exemple du
calcul des pensions alimentaires
c'est une bonne philosophie écoutez le
gouvernement veut accélérer pour tous il
veut moins de juges entre guillemets ou
moins d'action de juste comme dans le
cadre de la réforme constitutionnelle il
voudrait que le parlement aille plus
vite
est ce que c'est une bonne chose je n'en
suis pas convaincu du tout d'autant plus
que cela s'accompagnerait ou
s'accompagnera d'une modification de la
carte judiciaire dans mon département de
l'oise hier matin les avocats du barreau
de beauvais manifestaient devant la
crainte de cette fusion des tribunaux
d'instance et de grande instance devant
cette volonté de spécialiser certains
tribunaux qui ne vont aboutir qu'à une
seule chose aussi s'est éloigné le
justiciable de la justice et alors on
revient toujours à notre problématique
aussi de déplacement si l'ia
spécialisation des tribunaux ça voudra
dire que les justiciables devront rouler
plus consommer plus pollué plus où est
la logique
où est la cohérence gouvernementale même
dans la loi sur la justice
il ya une incohérence près nicole
belloubet 1 qui a fait une annonce
importante cette semaine c'était
mercredi lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
elle a affirmé son intention de réformer
par ordonnance la justice des mineurs
elle a déposé un amendement pour
réformer l'ordonnancé de 45 un dossier
auquel beaucoup de ses prédécesseurs
avaient renoncé car il est très sensible
alors gérard larcher et le cédant avait
demandé cette réforme de l'ordonnancé de
45 le sénat allait s'emparer de ce sujet
ce que la garde des sceaux a pris les
devants peut-être et écoutez si elle
veut réellement réformer cette
ordonnance de 45
nous l'y aideront bien volontiers les
enfants de 2000 la fal et les ados de
2018 ne sont plus ceux de 1945 il faut
qu'ils aient une adaptation ou l'avait
très bien dit de très nombreux hommes
politiques de très nombreux garde des
sceaux on parler d'une évolution de
cette ordonnance de 45 sur les mineurs
ils ne l'ont pas fait il est temps de le
faire et nous accompagnerons volontiers
la garde des sceaux dans la réforme si
elle va dans le bon sens
alors le gouvernement veut passer par
une ordonnance ce qu'il n'aurait pas
mieux valu une loi c'est un sujet qui
mérite un débat approfondi au parlement
oui oui bien sûr le parlement il est là
pour parlementer voie dans le sens noble
et donc il faut savoir prendre son temps
surtout sur des sujets aussi graves
aussi profond donc mieux vaut une loi
qu'une ordonnance oui alors on va
terminer cette émission avec l'assemblée
qui veut interdire la fessée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'objet d'une proposition de loi
défendue par le groupe modem elle a été
adoptée en commission mercredi le texte
ne prévoit pas de sanction mais inscrire
dans la loi le principe d'un droit à
l'éducation sans violence pour les
enfants les débats ont été évidemment
animer les partisans de la fessée ayant
donné de la voix
résumé mme a été vraiment sensibiliser
plutôt que sanctionner et voilà
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
sur l'interdiction des violences
éducatives ordinaires
en clair il ne serait pas question de
pénaliser les parents en cas de gif ou
de fait c'est ce texte porté par la
député modem mode petit et cosignée par
des élus d'autres groupes est avant tout
symbolique et a pour ambition d'inscrire
dans le code civil à l'article lu lors
des mariages que les titulaires de
l'autorité parentale l'exercent sans
violence s'il n'ya plus la fessée qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire
eh bien il ya bien d'autres modes de
façon d'éduquer ses enfants
il faut parler avec l'enfant faut
l'écouter il faut aller jouer au foot
avec sa fille il faut s'arrêter à
prendre un peu de temps pour cuisiner
avec son fils il faut être dans les
changes
ça ne veut pas dire plus de fait c'est
qu'il n'ya plus d'éducation il n'y a pas
une idée une fois cette loi votée de la
manière dont nous serons par an il n'y a
pas d'idée de prescription par contre
l'idée que c'est un point d'appui et une
aide à la parentalité pour sortir des
violences éducatives ordinaires oui je
considère que c'est un point d'appui
l'objectif est également de ce texte est
d'abolir le droit de correction encore
en vigueur dans la jurisprudence
mais certains députés ne semble pas prêt
à rompre avec des habitudes héritées de
l'enfance et dénonce une ingérence dans
la vie des familles alors je précise que
j'étais le père d'une famille de six
enfants peut-être que quelqu'un fait
mieux j'ai imposé des règles dans leur
éducation mes enfants tous adultes
aujourd'hui on ne manifeste aucune
critique
loin s'en faut à mon endroit on a parlé
de crise c'est à dire que si un parent
très énervé après une journée de travail
perd patience et se met à crier sur son
enfant c'est interdit par la loi
d'autres sont plus partagés et ne
souhaite clairement pas trop
chez ce départ fait il ya tout un
arsenal juridique bon est ce qu'il est
nécessaire d'en rajouter donc bien je
laisse la sagesse cette assemblée la
france est aujourd'hui l'un des six
derniers pays de l'union européenne à ne
pas avoir interdit les violences
éducatives ordinaires alors olivier
paccaud ce texte arrivera au sénat dans
les prochains mois quelle sera votre
position
écoutez vous savez les mots et la
bienveillance sont toujours préférable à
la violence
elle a fait c'est évidemment ils lui
sont toujours plus efficace néanmoins il
existe aujourd'hui un arsenal législatif
pour punir les violences envers les
enfants les violences parentales envers
les enfants faut-il aller plus loin je
n'en suis pas totalement convaincu cela
mérite questions et vous savez est
quelque chose dont on n'a pas parlé dans
les extraits que j'ai vu mais
l'indifférence c'est des fois bien plus
violent l'indifférence envers ses
enfants de la part de certains parents
c'est des fois bien plus violent et ça
malheureusement ce ne sera pas
sanctionnables par la loi alors si un
père de famille hausse des fois un peu
le ton emploi un mot malheureux un geste
inapproprié
faut-il le stigmatiser je n'en suis pas
convaincu mais évidemment toute violence
est plutôt à proscrire alors il ya dans
notre droit aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
un droit la correction tant que c'est
proportionnée ça ne me choque pas voilà
maintenant le fait que la france soit un
des rares pays d'europe à avoir encore
dans sa législation la permission de
fait c'est ça en choque certains je ne
suis pas convaincu que ce soit le
problème majeur de notre pays
aujourd'hui
mais est-ce que surtout c'est au
parlement de trancher ce type du sujet
n'est pas de l'ingérence familiale dans
certains cas si quand même
évidemment donc
le parlement il est là pour légiférer
mais il faut aussi des fois qu'il sache
ne pas légiférer à la sagesse des fois
c'est aussi de savoir effectivement ne
pas aller trop loin dans l' immixtion
dans la vie privée mais quand il ya de
véritables violences
il y a toutes les armes pour punir les
parents déficient merci merci merci
olivier d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine et nous t-bonds se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]